Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here.
You know, I think many people want to
learn a number of things, including
they want to learn languages.
I think a lot of people
don't know how to learn.
So my video today is about
learning how to learn.
And remember, if you enjoy
these videos, please subscribe.
You can click on the bell
and you'll get notifications.
Now, what I'm about to
say is very much personal.
How I view learning based on my
experience, watching others, what
works for me and the reading that I
have done about how the brain learns.
And I'm not a neuroscientist.
I often quote Manfred Spitzer
Lernen...you know, brain
research and the school of life.
And I just looked into my library,
you know, uh, The Mind and the Brain,
which talks about how we can will
our brain to do certain things.
The Right Mind.
I mean, there's lots of
books I've read on the brain.
My view is that to be successful
at learning, in other words, to
learn how to learn, you have to have
uh, an image, a vision of how
you think your brain learns.
Um, my vision of how my brain learns
is based on my experience and what
I've read on how the brain learns.
So I'm persuaded that our brain,
and Manfred Spitzer refers to this
quite often, our brain starts to
form neural connections between...
connections between neurons.
Uh, based on our experience.
And as long as the brain is
gaining new experience, it's
forming new neural connections.
So it's constantly learning,  the
brain cannot do otherwise than learn.
Um, however, Spitzer points out the brain
is not very good at learning details
because whatever it learns, it forgets.
So that the specific things that we are
trying to learn, which might be a list
of vocabulary items, it might be grammar
rules, it might be something else...
those things, we can retain
them for a short time and then
they're quickly forgotten.
But the underlying patterns in those
bits of information is what the brain
is very good at putting together.
And that's why the...
if we weren't able to do that, we
would be dealing with every situation
in life as if it was the first time
we ever encountered that situation.
Whereas in fact, what happens is the
brain builds up these patterns to enable
us to navigate our way through life.
That's true of everything
that happens to us in life.
It's true in language learning.
So my focus in language learning, as
I've said many times, is to expose
myself to as much language, if I'm
learning a language, language, content
as possible and not to worry too much
about specific rules, specific words.
Uh, you know, I saw a thing the
other day, teachers on Twitter were
saying, you know, should we teach kids
these words or those words?
You know, two different word lists.
It's not up to the teacher to decide
which words the kids should learn
or to attempt to teach these words.
All the teacher can do is to
provide an environment where the
learner is motivated, is interested
because it's something of interest.
And by being exposed to this over
and over again, gradually certain
patterns will form in the brain.
And so, you know, I'm
quite content in my Arabic.
I'm not ever going to test myself.
Uh, I'm just happy to listen to, uh,
you know, a transcript of an, of a
podcast, uh, go through it, maybe
in sentence view, maybe in full
text view, listen to it, read it.
Of course, if I spoke more, I'd get
better at speaking, but let's not
underestimate the power of listening
and reading because when you are
reading.,You're interpreting symbols and
converting those symbols into meaning.
That is a powerful
activity that is active.
That's not just passive.
Now we know, for example, you've heard
that say a London taxi driver who has
to memorize, has to get to know all the
little streets and alleyways in london.
That part of his brain, a certain
part of his brain grows as a result.
So yeah, all of our activity, even what
we might consider to be passive activity
in fact, is creating changes in the brain.
Learning is about change.
Learning is not about being
able to produce something.
Now, you know, here's
a test, get it right.
It's not about that.
It's about gradually exposing
yourself to a variety of stimulus,
allowing your brain to form patterns.
And, and having the confidence
that the brain is doing its job.
It's not going to do it, you
know, according to some timetable
that you set for the brain.
The brain learns, but
the brain learns slowly.
That's what Spitzer says.
Similarly, even if you are an adult say,
or an older person like me, and maybe
you create new neural connections more
slowly, or the plasticity of the brain
is not as quick as it used to be when you
were 12, on the other hand, the brain is
bringing in this information, relating
it to things that you already know,
experience, life, experience, knowledge,
vocabulary, uh, you know, knowledge
about different content areas and stuff.
All of which makes it easier
in some ways for you to learn.
But the process is essentially
the same and you have to have
confidence in that ability.
Once you've had enough exposure to
the language, uh, your brain has
started to form certain patterns.
If you want to look at some
rules to remind you of things
or to point some things out that
you didn't notice, that's fine.
But the idea that somehow the
brain can absorb specific rules or
specific lists, that they can, that
the brain can deliberately learn
these things at one sitting I think
has been increasingly debunked.
So learning to learn means learning
to learn in a way that corresponds to
how your brain learns or how you would
like to think of your brain learning,
because it's also very subjective.
And so putting pressure on yourself to,
uh, you know, to, to learn certain things
that I want to learn them now, eh, that
is not a very effective way of learning.
If you can find a way to enjoy, in
the case of languages, content, or
if you're trying to learn through the
language about the history of a certain
period, if you can get a variety of
different content items on a related
theme, where to some extent related
vocabulary is going to appear, and the
subject that you are gradually becoming
familiar with, you know, shows up in
all of these different stories, uh,
all of that is going to help you learn.
So, so you have to have this
approach of just letting it come
to you, having the confidence that
you can do it, um, enjoying the
process and trusting your brain.
I think a big part of learning how to
learn is to, to learn to trust your brain.
And don't worry whether you
got five out of 10 on a drill.
Uh, or whether you remembered a
certain, uh, you know, word list.
If the, the language comes
into you and you keep staying
with it, you're going to learn.
That's what you need to know.
That's to me learning how to learn.
Don't let the teacher impose
this word list or these
stories, get out and explore.
Let the brain enjoy the language.
Let yourself enjoy the language
and the brain will learn.
And I think learning how to learn
is, is no more complicated than that.
Yes, there are details on where you can
go find, you know, content of interest
and people can help you find that.
Or how do you, how do you utilize,
you know, Google translate or text
to speech or Netflix or YouTube or
LingQ or any of the other, you know,
online dictionaries and different
apps and all of that kind of stuff.
But those are the details again.
Learning how to learn to me means
having a, uh, um, sort of, uh, a
vision of yourself as a learner, which
corresponds to how the brain learns and
just sit back and enjoy the process.
And you will succeed.
You will succeed.
You have to believe that
you're going to succeed.
Don't second guess yourself.
And so that's what I wanted to talk about.
And, um, I'm going to leave you
with two videos that I did, uh,
Over the past few years, which touch
on the same theme because more or
less the, the theme is constant.
You have to believe in yourself
and you have to enjoy the process.